[Musique]
elle vous quand je vous regarde le midi
j'ai l'impression que vous savez pas
très bien pourquoi vous êtes là vraiment
pas le de william
ah oui c'est à dire que je pense qu'il
fallait pas qu'ils viennent sur la
chaîne parce que c'est une erreur de
casting
je trouve que ça n'a pas lieu d'être
c'est une émission qui est très molle
oui je pense
le midi on va pas sauter en l'air et au
style de williams et on n'est pas obligé
de s'endormir non plus il dote bettina
moi je trouve que c'est un mauvais
recrutement est il difficile ne croyez
pas parce qu'on a bien sûr leurs années
de de télé que tout d'un coup en ce sens
là dedans des enjeux à l'aise c'est pas
si facile que ça de sortir de sa zone de
confort de francs et 2 et puis d'arriver
dans un truc qui est un challenge
coiffer pour nous qui à ma place à la
wii j'aurais pas fait l'émission en fait
pas du tout je pense que c'est très
décevant
la nouvelle édition savait plus de riz
je vous dis la vérité je préfère mille
fois oui la baby